a senior taliban official has told sky
news that the issue of girls education
in afghanistan should not be used
against the regime today marks one year
since the taliban marched into kabul and
reclaimed power but afghanistan is
facing an economic and humanitarian
catastrophe with foreign governments
refusing to send aid until the rights of
afghans particularly
women and girls are respected
foreign
well that was
a senior taliban leader speaking to our
chief correspondent stuart ramsey who
joins me now live from kabul and stuart
you were there
um obviously a year ago give us a sense
of how things have deteriorated in the
space of a year
basically it's the economy mark and and
the whole medical sector is completely
falling apart 95 percent of hospitals uh
are expected to close uh quite soon it's
completely overloaded the economy is a
massive problem and that's really what
mr haqqani is saying is basically we
know the west has a real problem uh with
with the education of of young girls and
they're linking it to the fact that
they're not giving us aid and they're
not unfreezing our assets what he is
basically saying
the young guard will be able to change
this but you've we have to separate the
two issues because people are going to
die in huge numbers as we get to the
winter because there's just not the sort
of aid the billions of dollars of aid
that they were used to getting and he's
appealing for that to come what he's
basically saying is if we can get that
sorted and separated then we will be
able to bring the old guard on board in
the future i do have to say that like
that is a big jump of faith
for countries like the united states and
great britain however there is a
consensus building amongst other
governments and particularly the ngos
that we can't just leave
the people of afghanistan to die in the
winter months they're starving already
it's only going to get worse of course
we just can't afford to leave them b
because
the government's
lost after 20 years and don't like the
taliban and i think that's the big leap
of faith that would have to be made but
mr khan does make a real point they can
potentially pull the old guard through
but there has to be separated because
you can take your time on the education
of young women but you can't take your
time on the starvation of almost the
entire country